hello, how are you, health, andrés gonzález,
with the brief information for today, Thursday
, May 27, if you are looking for work,
I will tell you that there are several companies
around the valley hiring
men, for example, and if they seek to have
300 positions in different areas of the
resort  waitress security maintenance
among others must have a
job fair today at 8 in the morning
until noon and the second session will be from
2 to 6 in the afternoon dress to impress
because the interviews will be there
but not only the casinos are hiring
the department  of firefighters
seeks to increase the number of
paramedics and firefighters for this
job you must fill out your application before
July 3 for more information
you can visit disney.com diagonal in
Spanish
and the fire station located on
the prime box near the lounge organizes
a  vaccination clinic today
from 8 in the morning until noon
visit our page of news now
diagonal in Spanish  ñol to make an
appointment
the
las vegas convention and visitors authority approved a
budget of 280 million dollars
for this fiscal year much of the
money will be directed towards
important events among these are
the nfl draft rodeo finals and
races  of nascar out of 750,000
will be used for
the 4th of July celebrations another large amount will be
saved for the new year
and now we now pass the weather forecast
we will have a hot day
approaching 100 degrees
by today we will see
temperatures rise  for the weekend
reaching 100 for the Monday holiday
the heat will continue to enter
officially for the first week of
June have a nice day I am andrés
gonzález and that was your brief informative
the news now in Spanish
[Music]